[Music]
hey guys now I get a lot of messages
from people on social media and on
YouTube that ask me hey Daniel please
give me a few tips to look better but at
the same time a lot of them complain and
say I don't look as good as other people
and that's the problem you should stop
trying to compare yourself to other
people or try to look better than them
or better than your friends your goal
should always be just to improve
yourself
the idea here is not to compete against
other people but to compete against
yourself so that you are better than the
you from yesterday you see what I'm
saying so that being said in this video
I'm gonna give you 10 tips 10 simple
things that every guy can do to look
better let's get to it I have a dream
[Music]
made mistakes but mistakes make you
strong now just very quick if your first
time here on my channel I'm Daniel and
welcome to D LM model lifestyle consider
subscribing and also taking that
notification belt so you won't miss any
of the next videos now let's not waste
any more time let's get right into the
first step you gotta get into grooming
now I can talk a lot about this but let
me just mention a few things if you only
have two or three hairs shave it off
because chances are you're the type of
guy that looks better shaved your not
gonna look good with just three or four
long hairs but that just looks no no no
but on the other hand if you do have a
nice beard trim it the right way so it
fits in with your face shape and her
hair style but please if you do have a
beard please turn these neck hair here
because if you just leave them here you
look like a lazy slob now I feel like I
almost don't have to say this because
you probably already know this but if
you're uncomfortable with your body do
something about it
if you feel overweight it will look
better if you get in shape and if you
lose some weight on the other hand if
you're too skinny gain some muscle and
start to live a healthy lifestyle why
well because if you eat healthier if you
maintain a healthy lifestyle you will
have more energy to take on the
challenges that everyday brings clothes
number two will also look a lot better
on you number three you will be feel and
look healthy to other people and number
four you also give you a lot more
confidence in yourself so be honest with
yourself just look at yourself in the
mirror if you're not happy with the way
you look they start today and change it
because here's the truth we can't always
change our genes that we got from our
mom and dad right but we can change our
bodies at the gym or eating healthy
you gotta get more hygienic I mean you
might get used to yourself the way you
smell your sweat and your breath but I
guarantee you that other people can pick
it up quickly and it is very off-putting
if you just walk around and suddenly you
smell something or if you stand with a
few friends and you smell like oh man
and then you wonder why somebody just
leaves or try to avoid you so all you
got to do is when you get out of the
shower with some antiperspirant on and
then you're safe for the whole day you
know you're not gonna smell all right
second when you brush your teeth brush
your tongue as well and then also your
nails dirty nails is a big no-no so take
care of your nails so that they are
short and clean
get into skincare why because your skin
represents you every single day of your
life now some guys still think that yeah
it's not so important it's fine I'm just
I just look like what I am I don't need
to take care of myself but then they
wonder why so many women out there are
not so interested in them I can assure
you if you have a girlfriend or a wife
they will love it if you take care of
your skin
it's not about self-importance but it
has to do with self-respect think about
this for a while do you think that it is
always easy for a woman to shave her
legs shave her underarms to walk in high
heels
put on makeup and dress up to do all
this effort for you
of course not so you can also do a
little bit of effort you don't have to
go crazy but you can just start a basic
skincare routine that will help you to
look better and healthier and if you're
not sure which products to use I'll add
a few good options for you in a video
description down below and you can check
out
know your weak points and how to control
it effectively nobody is perfect not me
and now you we all have weak points
first you gotta learn how to accept it
and then you also need to learn how to
control it so let me share some of my
weak points
I've always had a big forehead and a
receding hairline right so I never wear
my hair all the way back but I bring it
a little bit forward
and also I don't have any calls I've got
very very small Cubs but I got from my
dad I accepted it but I will never ever
wear baggy shorts because then it just
looks even smaller so all I do is I just
wear slim fit shorts and then it looked
better
I'm not shy to share these things with
you guys because I'm just a normal human
being just like you I am completely
content with all my weak points because
I've learned how to handle it the right
way and so can you
unwanted hair let's talk about this you
got a trim your hair if you start to get
those unwanted hair like the nose hair
you gotta trim it because when you are
into a conversation with somebody
they'll be distracted a lot more with
those hair creeping out then what you're
saying in the conversation and if you
have those hair right between your
eyebrows get rid of it now you don't
have to tweeze all your eyebrows but if
you have a unibrow he's gotta go but
then again if you have also those Bush
kind of eyebrows then you can also
tweeze them just a little bit to look
more natural but please never wax it
because then you have those fixed
straight lines and just leave that for
women
you gotta choose the right size clothing
a lot of people miss this never wear
oversized clothes like those huge baggy
jeans or on the other end there's very
super skinny jeans and especially if
you're buff you got a lot of muscle
don't be that guy you know the guy that
walks around like this his two shirts
that are too small for him because he
just wants everybody to see his body
they can see right through you and most
people actually hate it because nobody
likes puffed up arrogant people walking
around with that expression on their
face that says oh look at me no that's
just off-putting but confidence that is
humble is always attractive and wearing
clothes that hold close to your body is
most flattering not to sizes too small
or too sizes too big all you got to do
is just look for slim fit labels on
clothing good communication and good
posture this is extremely important why
well because when you speak with people
it always looks better if you have good
posture and if you speak clearly and
with confidence it changes your whole
look imagine if I did this video with
just a slouchy posture like this and
then if I just speak softened a little
bit unclear not making eye contact not
energy
you see what I mean so you might say
yeah I will Daniel it's easy for you to
say well actually no it's not I had to
teach myself to adopt these new habits
it is skills that everybody can learn
it's just it just feels so hard at the
beginning because you're just so used to
your old habits
invest in a classic wardrobe now it's
important not to buy clothes just
because you want to but invest in good
quality clothing that will never ever go
out of style so that you can wear it for
a very long time because it saves you
money and you also look stylish timeless
basic clothing is a backbone of my own
and any other stylish guys wardrobe out
there the basics of a navy suit or a
blazer white dress shirts dark denim
easy to layer tees and even an
all-purpose trench coat means that you
will always be able to appear stylish
and you can also add stylish and trendy
items to the classic look and hey if you
want to look into the basic clothing
essentials I'll add my list for in the
video description that you can check out
check your attitude if you've got all
the other nine tips down but your
attitude stinks those 9 tips it's not
gonna help you at all
but humility is the greatest quality
that man can have and arrogance is
undoubtedly the worst and there's a very
very thin line between confidence and
arrogance and you need to know the
difference it doesn't matter what you
achieve in your life it doesn't give you
the right to look down on other people
arrogance is used by the weak and
insecure but kindness is used by the
strong and it is much needed in the
world that we live in today now if
you're new here on my channel you might
like one of these videos and remember to
subscribe and I'll see you in the next
video search guys